Now that you have a handle on adding polynomials, let's try subtracting them.
When we subtract polynomials we need to subtract the second quantity. We can
think of this problem just like this problem. We know in this problem we don't
just subtract the one, we need to subtract a total of six. So we can subtract
the 1, subtract the 2 and subtract the 3. This is why these parentheses are so
important they indicate that when you subtract a total of 6 and not just a total
of 1. We get an answer of 9 here but this isn't so important, whats important is
what we did right here. We distributed a negative 1, we're going to use the same
line of thinking for tackling this whenever you subtract a quantity, you want to
change every single sign because we're multiplying by a negative one. So I
multiply each term by negative 1 and really that just changes all their signs.
You don't have to show this step in your problem solving, but if it helps, you
do it. Here's our expression after we multiply by negative 1. Once we're here we
carry out the problem just like addition. We regroup our like terms, and then we
combine them x squared plus 2x plus 2. Here's our final polynomial.